even though this is going against
science my balance is impeccable yoyoyo
I've just decided I feel like doing
something special so this one's for you
[Music]
my name is Dan mace and I'm a youtuber I
used to be a film director and before
that my only other job was being a surf
coach at the store and even though the
term youtuber for many means living my
best life every single day money that
shoots out of this endless cash
generator called an adsense account it
doesn't actually work that way
that is of course unless your content is
super clean massively engaging and
sustainable to push up every single day
and on top of that you getting a million
plus views every single day which is a
very tiny portion of content creators on
the platform with analytics like these
you're getting between two to three
thousand dollars every single day which
is about sixty to seventy thousand
dollars a month a similar salary to a
michelin-star chef a best-selling writer
or professional sportsman and then for
smaller to medium weekly uploaded
youtubers like myself we make between
two to four thousand dollars a man
through the YouTube ad revenue system
this is the same salary as an
entry-level teacher janitor staff or
store assistant manager because I want
to grow the platform and creates a
really collaborative space for all kinds
of filmmakers like yourself and paying
for a space like this and paying my
manager and my assistant insurance
medical aide give my fiancees shoe
collection that's a joke and my personal
life expenses that actually leaves me in
- and that's where the brand deals come
in
od grill this means I can travel employ
my friends to work on my brand most
importantly right now structure 20 new
episodes for season 2 and I just bought
a house
[Music]
disclaimer this doesn't mean I love an
essay now I will be returning to New
York at the beginning of next year very
important when working with brands I
always make sure that they are honorable
and somewhat conquering the market in
their field but this week was a disaster
I checked my calendar and my deliverable
said go tracts jxl scoot integration
amethyst round product ticks all the
boxes it's the number one most purchased
electric scooter on Amazon as well as
the number one most trusted and we don't
have something like this in South Africa
triple take it arrived in the post I put
it together and it had no batteries this
is because South Africa has this really
strict rule after a few cell phones
explode in a while if a lithium battery
is punctured the chemicals react which
creates a fire how am I gonna make an ad
with a product that doesn't work time to
go to the drawing board
this is me quite literally making an
impossible ad ideally I'd want to show
the functionality of the electronic
scooters moving up again but because
this is impossible
it's time for a good old-fashioned
low-budget foam sheet I'm going to try
and ride the scooter backwards down a
hill which is really stupid for three
reasons one because you're using the
front axle to turn as the back wheel and
it's bound to spin out violently to my
body will be facing away from the
direction that I'm headed and on top of
that
looking back will just throw off my
balance and three the back rake is now a
really sharp front brake which will
propel me forward
or rather backwards if pressing down on
a choppy
problem solved now to storyboard aside
time to make the first-ever
anti ad to make the world's worst piece
of advertising to create attention as I
can't while you in any other way the
idea here is to find the perfect heel
well that's not too steep or one that's
not too flat we're gonna give you
something that's just perfect like this
[Music]
wow this is really great I am going up a
hill it even makes me feel faster and I
can fly oh yeah I know fish should be
forming our hobbies carry live a skittle
is gonna lose you know where do you know
a conservatism
[Music]
that's fun painful there yeah that's
right it's time I thinks just a
contusion
what's a contusion is a big brute know
you're gonna be I want stitches for the
clickbait no you don't need to ditches
yeah but I could not talk yeah that's
fun
what do you mean do you mind if I sign
out my phone man yeah my doctor says I'm
gonna be okay which is good news for my
health but bad news for the clickbait
but in all seriousness the scooter is
great yes some clips of my manager will
you riding around in your cooler have
some talking points it's fun do you know
the talking points are it's it's
portable super portable it's range it
goes really far twelve and a half miles
go to the link below if you get it with
a battery it's really cool what a day
before you go anywhere there's something
I read this morning on Twitter that
really struck a chord with me something
that I think is super relevant and I
want to read it here Shekar broke my
phone New York is three hours in of
California but it doesn't make
California slow someone graduates at the
age of twenty-two but waited five years
before securing a good job someone
became a CEO 25 and died at 50 while
another became CEO at 50 and lived 290
years
someone is still single or someone else
got married
Obama retired at 55 and Trump started at
17 everyone in this world works based on
their timezone people around you may
seem to be ahead of them and some may
seem to be behind you when everyone is
running their own race in the
do not envy them and do not Martin they
are in their time zone and you are in
yours
life is about waiting for the right
moment to act though relax we're not
late you're not - and you are very much
on time rad and I'm gonna leave you
there this week if you new here please
subscribe let me know what you thought
in the comments below and put your
notifications bell on also like the
video other than that you're awesome
drew and I'll see you next week
Wednesday
[Music]
[Music]